The Joe Rogan Experience basically long
story short
PhD student drop out of the PHD go to
work at Wall Street Wall Street blows up
I come back to Tech right or back to
Tech I never worked in Tech but I gone
to school in Berkeley and I had seen
kind of the first tech bubble so I was
kind of vaguely aware of it
joint Tech join ad Tech do my own
startup
tiny little company not a big success
get sold to Twitter I end up at Facebook
a year before the IPO as one of the
early members of the ads team so if you
go like browse for [ __ ] on the internet
and you see that same pair of shoes
inside your Instagram feed or whatever I
created the very first versions initial
not what's there now versions of that so
a lot of the I was the first like
product manager for ads targeting so
like how user data gets turned into a
successful ads campaign is what I was
responsible for in a very formative
period in the company's history and so I
was there again not that terribly long
but it was a lot happened the company
went grew in size enormously and figured
out how to make money like I didn't know
how to [ __ ] make money the ads the
ads as everyone remembers used to suck
and now everyone's like ads are either
creepy or crappy there's no in between
so they went from crappy to creepy
um it was a big team a lot of people did
stuff to make that happen so the book is
about that like how do you start a
company how do you raise money the inner
workings of Silicon Valley I went
through this famous incubator thing
called White combinator when you say
crappy to creepy do you mean invasive
yeah yeah in the sense of like oh this
is like totally relevant to like oh I
was literally just searching for this
thing and here's an ad for it let me ask
you about this because we've talked
about this multiple times in the podcast
sometimes you're having a conversation
oh God the microphone thing is that real
no no it's not real no no I mean I don't
believe them see no no I'm just talking
about something the other day I haven't
searched for it at all okay and I got an
ad for it something me and you were
talking about what was it I if I
remember right I couldn't remember but
it was something we're talking about
after the show
six hours later I'm getting an ad for it
here's what I'd bet on one of you two
either searched or went to some website
not only one of us what so if I do he
gets an app yeah that potentially yeah
how uh the term of art is called
look-alike audiences what that means is
so some retailer knows that you dump a
bunch of money at whatever REI Cabela's
pick your favorite retailer whatever
you two are Buds and you interact a lot
on whatever social media platform if I'm
Cabela say just a cited example I'm like
okay I know this guy is worth whatever
two thousand dollars a year get me more
people like him and companies like
Facebook or other companies can say aha
well guess what he talks to this dude a
lot who by the way whose profile kind of
looks like yours and so you will get
targeted for something that you did yeah
I get that but we have very different
online things you know I look at
sneakers and stuff he's looking at
hunting and whatnot the thing that came
up I wish I could I normally take a
screenshot when these things happen
because I'll share it with the person
yeah like Luca just popped up on my
phone
this was outside of that yeah this is
one of those things I go all right we
need to talk about this but again I know
there's uh okay so let me love fences to
it but this was let me address the
question it's funny there's a there's a
Planet Money show about this in which
they talked to various people who had
this experience try to figure out how it
actually happened I was I was a guest on
it but let me address the problem so
imagine imagine let's say let's say
Marcus Zuckerberg is listening to her
conversations and gets like a live
stream of your phone all the time
what fraction of the time do you think
you're actually mentioning something
commercially interesting that would be
worth like targeting against like how
often do you say hey I'm flying to
Boston next week and I need a flight in
a hotel on a taxi and you say it in some
structured way that would be easy it
it's pretty rare right and the amount of
I mean think about the amount of data
you'd have to you'd be on a constant
phone call basically to Zucker would eat
up your network like crazy and then the
fraction of the times versus you just
like going to [ __ ] kayak and like
entering Boston and using that data and
so it I'm not saying it's technically
impossible and in some future world who
knows but it would be difficult and even
if you manage to do it there isn't one
of the things one of the chapters of my
book I I understand you're listening to
have a chapter called the narcissism of
privacy which comes off maybe more
snarky than I mean but
privacy is a right and people have a
right to it obviously but I think one of
the sort of misleading things when you
think about companies like Facebook is
that like Facebook wants to know the
thing that you least want them to know
which is like your personal conversation
with your loved one or whatever when it
comes to commercial data that actually
helps Target ads there's very little
very little of what you do or things
that you wouldn't think of are what they
want not necessarily what you would like
what you would
not want Facebook to know right but what
concerns people is the idea that your
microphone is picking up keywords that
they have accounts with so whether it's
uh cell phones tires whatever it is then
you see an ad for it it would be more
possible in like the smart speaker
systems you have at home for example
right that that really wouldn't be so
hard to do yeah stuff like that probably
would be so hard to do that makes sense
and so how would they target you for an
ad with that
well again if you said something well
structured that would be easy to tease
out and if that's connected to the same
account that's connected to your Gmail
or your Google search or Amazon or
Amazon then they would show you the ads
yeah yeah so like a lot of what happens
that's actual targeting is like data
joining so like getting back to the
Cabela's example like I understand
you're into hunting so maybe you shop at
the local Cabela's or the Bass Pro Shop
um they'll have your phone number and
email for all the [ __ ] you buy online
and what they want to do is like find
you online and sell you because it's the
[ __ ] deer hunting season sale or
whatever and they try to and so what
they'll do is they'll upload that list
of emails to Facebook and say oh this is
the this is the deer hunting group and
then they'll show you ads based on your
actual buying history so that sort of
thing absolutely does happen yes that
makes sense what is it like being in
those companies like whether it's
Facebook or you know any any sort of
tech company for someone on the outside
we we look at it and we say like how are
those [ __ ] places run because it's
like I've had a good friend who was a
big executive at Google and now she
works at another large tech company and
the way she described it to me she's
like it is utter Madness it's utter
Madness and the lunatics of running the
Asylum to a certain extent because
there's a lot of people the company that
she works for now there's a lot of
people that are inside the company that
legitimately are mentally ill and they
consider themselves activists and they
have to placate them because there's a
certain percentage of the population of
the people that work for the company and
they're the loudest and they oftentimes
don't get work done and when confronted
they could they talk about their
activism right and like she's like
listen you are here for you know x
amount of hours a day this is your
[ __ ] job you're not an activist right
and don't think that if you're
complaining about other things that this
company does that you doing that is a
part of your job because it is not
yeah I mean I think the companies are
somewhat to blame because they've done
the whole like bring a real self to work
thing right and again what is that
there's this philosophy among like the
HR there that like
and if you're being cynical about it
it's engineered to get the most
productivity out of you like the real
the real self to like if you work at
some of these companies particularly
again to answer your question I think it
depends what stage of the company you
join but you're talking about big
companies like apple Google Facebook now
um it it's a campus it's a lifestyle
they do your laundry for you they feed
you there's like they do your laundry
they can't yeah yeah there's like apple
does your laundry I'm not sure about
Apple because we were never in office
because it was still undercovered but
Facebook had had laundry I'm sure Google
does yeah whoa yeah it's it's weird it's
you join I mean
it's a strained analogy but it's kind of
like a cult and there's like a massive
amount of corporate culture like I
described this a lot in chaos monkeys
who said that who who said that quote
that every successful startup is a
culture I think was Keith Urban I think
from Founders fun and the thing is he's
right he's right like Facebook was a
cult and I joined it and I was a happy
member of it it was very powerful
everyone sacrificed themselves for the
sake of the Facebook Empire and its
Emperor did it change your own personal
thinking while you were there in the
cult oh yeah did you subscribe Escalade
oh yeah I totally bled blue I still do a
certain yeah absolutely because again
it's a formative experience like some of
the most impactful professional work I
did was there like it or not making
taking Facebook ads from like the shitty
stupid little iPad offer ads on the
right to like literally the thing you
just looked at or bought which I know
sounds cringy whatever that changed
everything I was one of many to be clear
it wasn't just me but that changed
everything about that company and was
super impactful inside the industry like
how much of an impact did it have when
Apple came along long and in introduce
these restrictions yeah you're talking
about ATT which is like the ads
transparency thing for those who don't
know if you've got an iPhone like you
you download an app and suddenly there's
like this opt-in that apple is showing
you saying hey do you want to share your
data with these people that's hugely
impactful what that does is so why does
that matter so Apple controls this they
create the hardware and the software and
all of it right right at the end of the
day seen from Apple's point of view
Facebook as powerful As It Seems
is just another app in the app store
right which was always zuck's fear which
is why he wanted to build a phone
Apple can say look Facebook you can't
you don't get to track users as well as
you used to you can't track Joe Rogan
down or like anonymously your device ID
you can't do that anymore you only get a
certain level of granularity it's how
much tracking were they able to do that
before that well I mean an infinite
amount they would track you individually
I mean whether it's worth doing and
that's another matter but they would get
the individual device ID from your phone
and so they would know who you are in
terms of that phone
what does that entail
like again you know you if if you go to
if you go to Cabela's and buy a thing
then you go to some you're playing a
casual game and they show you an ad
you playing that game and you buying
that thing in Cabela's can be
individually joined in a very precise
way and if you remove that and say oh
you can't track Joe Rogan's phone you're
tracking a hundred thousand people out
of throw then they bucketize you they
put you in a bucket that isn't quite as
precise as before and what that
translates into is fewer clicks fewer
sales like the effective amount of money
that either The Advertiser makes or the
publisher that's showing the admix goes
down
now is this for the end user for the
person who has the phone is it
beneficial that they've instituted these
policies good question
um
if you get a warm fuzzy feeling inside
knowing you're not being individually
tracked yes but other than that
not particularly but it also doesn't
give up the access
to your data that's this very valuable
commodity for Facebook
right
um
so here's the tricky thing about data
right one of the one of the many
misconceptions that I try to address in
the book about how Facebook works is
it's often not Facebook data that's
being used to Target you because if you
think about Facebook right it's like
you're posting random photos you're
engaging with content but a lot of your
commercial activity like booking
airplane flights shopping for [ __ ]
doesn't happen on Facebook Facebook
doesn't know about that strictly
speaking so how how do they solve that
problem that like we got to show him
[ __ ] shoe ads and Facebook doesn't
know [ __ ] about what shoes you like
right right so part of this is what I
describe in the book and what I helped
build in the early stages
there's a way of joining you Joe Rogan
Facebook you to Cabela's u in some
relatively data safe way that that lets
Cabela show you an ad for those shoes
Facebook doesn't necessarily know all
the Cabela [ __ ] because Cabela's doesn't
want to let Facebook know that [ __ ]
because they don't trust Facebook right
and so a lot of the stuff that's going
on isn't like oh Facebook knows
everything about you it's like no
Facebook knows who you are on every
device because you tend to use Facebook
everywhere maybe not you but other
people and so that means that they can
join you very well to all the other
commercial activity you do and you use
Facebook a lot so they have lots of
opportunities to maybe show you an asset
that's really Facebook's strength but
getting back to the original question
how does Apple [ __ ] that up well it
[ __ ] it up because it doesn't know who
you are on that device at the individual
granular level anymore and so it can't
talk to Cabela's and say oh that guy
who's will look for these weird things
like show them this ad that that can't
happen anymore is it in any way negative
for the person who's the end user good
question
um because maybe you would want to see
those those ads because this is
something that you you're actually
interested in purchasing I mean in the
happy case but let's face I mean in the
happy case well if you're a person who's
you know you have full control over your
urges you're not a person who's just
like get you know you don't you can't
afford something but you buy it anyway
because you're [ __ ] crazy and you saw
the ad and you can't help yourself
because we know that there are people
like that out there right so in the best
case scenario is it better I would think
so
but isn't that like what you do as a
business
let's go is a lot better than the like
stupid punch the monkey ads used to
surround Those ads and like Display band
you probably don't remember them but
like in yahoo.com back in the day to be
like a little moving Target and then
like punch the monkey like you can
either see that [ __ ] or you can
actually see an ad that maybe has a
chance of being relevant in Instagram
feed so yeah you give anything up to
have those relative ads
No in fact I mean you gain things right
like a lot of services wouldn't exist if
they weren't paid for Via ads so like
the reality is
if Facebook's ads start sucking more I.E
the amount of money they make per ads
goes down they're just going to show you
more ads so do you think that Android
phones handle it better
because Android phones allow more of
those things in yeah super wonky
question I wasn't expecting this joke
it's wonky yeah no no no it's good I
think I love talking about it but um
the model that Google and apple have are
somewhat different
um apple is a fully you know vertically
integrated thing they create literally
the chips and the software you're
looking at Google's a little bit
different
um you can buy Android phones made by
all sorts of Manufacturers their model
in general tends to be a little bit more
open to third parties and so there's a
whole ads ecosystem in Google where I
could [ __ ] fill this wall or white
board with all the little boxes all the
little companies that like get together
to show you a single ad and so Google is
a little bit better about
being more open to the outside mind you
they still use Monopoly power in various
ways like they're not Saints
um but apple has a more closed note
approach to I mean that's why they're
building an ad system because they want
to make money in ads but they're not
going to go to the Google route they're
going to build more than likely I mean
not that I have deep insight into it
anymore but more than likely they're
going to build it themselves because
they have a more closed vision of it
that how they think about data privacy
here's another thing people want to geek
out One Direction Apple's going that's
kind of interesting is that a lot of the
data for your iPhone's going to live on
device like in other words for the past
20 plus years of Internet we've had this
model where like you do [ __ ] on a phone
data goes into the cloud weird [ __ ]
happens and you get shown a page or an
experience a lot of that's changing
right like probably most of what you do
on a phone is through an app it's not a
browser anymore it's like the code is
running on your on your phone you're
producing data on that phone like why
shouldn't the computation and all the
[ __ ] that happens happen on the phone
these phones are actually pretty
powerful right um and so a lot of things
are moving in that direction for a bunch
of reasons one of the reasons actually
is privacy and you know apple and other
companies have made a public statements
about this was like oh it's more private
like what's the ultimate opt out my
data's on this phone you know I do I
take it I throw into the [ __ ] Lake
their data's gone right wow like opt out
and deletion when the data's in the
cloud and a bunch of third parties have
it you never really know right right but
if you keep the data on the phone it is
better in many ways